how can you be unique I'm going to
answer that question in today's episode
of ask Evan greetings everybody from New
Orleans I got a question for one of my
loyal youtube subscribers love you guys
Alyssa who wrote in to say I have a
question I want to inspire people in
beauty and fashion I have a channel but
how can I have a unique message in such
a broad area so as a fantastic question
and Alyssa I feel for you and the thing
is in every industry is competitive
right every industry is competitive and
the key is you got to be you the key
thing that's going to make you stand out
from everybody else is you I'm trying to
cross the street as I'm saying this
that's a differentiator that's your
market advantage and so you've got to
figure out yes you can model success yes
you can look at people who are big in
the beauty industry and look at how they
rose and those are great examples you
got to take what work for them and then
making your own you've got to find a way
to make this your business and people
will be attracted to your personality
not everybody but a certain group of
people and when I found the best way to
do it is to combine your passions so if
you love beauty that's amazing that's
awesome what else do you love how can
you mix those two things so for example
say you love dancing right you love
dancing that's your passion besides
beauty be the beauty person for dancers
right the next I'm doing a photo shoot
the next time we're getting ready for a
performance the next time they're out
there getting into movie almost got run
over by that guy holy cow they're going
to call you right you're making videos
your written blog posts you're tweeting
about makeup and beauty and dancing
oh that's the cue that's how you do it a
couple examples that I've used before in
the video one you know if you like being
a photographer photographers are super
competitive too let's say you love
bowling then you can be the photographer
for bowlers and you're going to be the
default person they go to because they
need people to take pictures and they
want somebody who's passion about
bowling if you love dancing they need
people who can do makeup but they want
people who are passionate all dancing as
well and you can speak both languages
that's the key I got a buddy of mine
I've used example before named Steve who
is a financial planner make a financial
planner how many financial planners are
there out there tons but he has a
passion for hockey he loves hockey he
obsesses over it he watches it you know
as much as he can watch is the same
replay 20 times he could just watch
hockey day in day out he became the
financial planner for hockey players and
so when he's talking to hockey players
now he can speak their language he can
talk about hockey you talk about
investments and he's one of them right a
lot of these hockey players you know
that the goal and financial planning is
to target the high net worth individuals
right the people have a lot of money
those people who you want to work with
and so he's able to do that by combining
his passions and so make it your own
right find a way to be able to tie
whatever other packages you have into
the beauty business and that's how
you're going to stand out I want to see
more lists I want to see your passion I
want to see your personality your
character what you believe in all of
that there's got to be real it's gotta
be you it's got to be human and that
connection to you and everything that
you stand for and believed in this which
is what's going to make me want to come
to you as opposed everybody else that's
how you stand up okay everybody watching
I want to know I want to know how you
stand down I want to know what makes you
different leave in the comments below on
a journey discussion thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon whoo it is hot here in New
Orleans